Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Now England, old England, still hold up thy head, who lately by popery long time hath been led, and let the Pope's actors that played all their pranks be gone in all haste or will cripple their shanks, for in heart, voice and loyalty Mary will be in the crowning of William and brave Queen Mary.
感谢收听《历史的 Rest》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。现在，英国，古老的英国，依然昂起你的头，不久前你曾长期被天主教教皇统治，让那些耍弄各种把戏的教皇爪牙赶快滚蛋，否则就打断他们的双腿，因为在内心、声音和忠诚上，玛丽将在加冕威廉和勇敢的玛丽女王时发挥作用。
So they got up on horseback to Rome for to ride and God bless great William that turned the tide. He kicked those old mass mongers quite out of door with a downfall forever to Babylon's whore. And now Popa is banished, as all men can see, in the crowning of William and brave Queen Mary. So that, Tom Holland, is a splendid broadside ballad published in 1689 to celebrate the coronation of William III and Mary II. Was it by any chance written by a Protestant? I think it possibly was.
于是他们骑马上路前往罗马，愿上帝保佑扭转乾坤的伟大的威廉。他把那些老弥撒贩子赶出了家门，让巴比伦的妓女彻底倒台。现在教皇已被流放，正如所有人都能看到的，在威廉和勇敢的玛丽女王的加冕典礼上。汤姆·霍兰，这是一首宏伟的宽版歌谣，发表于1689年，旨在庆祝威廉三世和玛丽二世的加冕典礼。它会不会是某个新教徒写的？我想很可能是。
So that's in the aftermath of the Glorious Revolution when James II, our last Catholic king, was kicked out. The coronation oath that King Charles will be swearing at the weekend reflects the legacy of the Glorious Revolution. Tom, we think of coronations as timeless rituals, but as this reminds us, they are in fact reflections of changing political and religious passions. And of course, what you make of a given coronation, I suppose, that reflects who's writing the history, doesn't it? It absolutely does. And that is something that takes us, actually, Dominic, very conveniently,
所以那是在光荣革命之后的余波中，詹姆斯二世，我们最后的天主教国王被赶下台。查尔斯国王在这个周末将宣誓的加冕誓言，反映了光荣革命的遗产。汤姆，我们认为加冕典礼是永恒的仪式，但正如这提醒我们的那样，它们实际上是不断变化的政治和宗教热情的反映。当然，你对某一特定加冕典礼的看法，我想，这反映了是谁在书写历史，不是吗？确实如此。这实际上把我们带到了，多米尼克，非常合适的时候，
you were talking about timeless coronations. So in the previous episode, we were talking about how you can trace the order of service that is going to be used on Saturday all the way back to the 10th century and the reign of Edgar. And this order of service was drawn up by St. Dunstan, the great Archbishop of Canterbury in the 10th century. But Dunstan featured in another coronation, and that was the coronation of Edgar's elder brother, Edwy. And Dunstan and Edwy did not get on at all. And the accounts that were written of Edwy's coronation seem to have been, well, if not written by Dunstan himself, then certainly by fans of Dunstan. So this is the second canonical coronation, is it? So Edgar was the first and this is number two, is that right?
你刚才谈到了永恒的加冕典礼。所以在上一集里，我们讨论了你是如何将周六将要使用的仪式顺序一直追溯到10世纪埃德加统治时期的。这个仪式顺序是由10世纪坎特伯雷伟大的大主教圣邓斯坦制定的。但邓斯坦在另一次加冕典礼中也扮演了角色，那就是埃德加的哥哥埃德维的加冕典礼。邓斯坦和埃德维根本合不来。关于埃德维加冕典礼的记载，似乎——如果不是邓斯坦本人写的，也绝对是邓斯坦的粉丝写的。所以这是第二个规范的加冕典礼，是吗？埃德加是第一个，这是第二个，对吗？
No, Edwy is before. So Edwy is the elder brother brother oh right sorry i'm all i'm completely out of kilter so edward is crowned in kingston upon thames in 956 so that's almost 20 years before ed was later coronation in bath and according to the uh biography of dunstan he behaves very very badly so he's been crowned yeah and instead And instead of hanging around and, you know, doing what a king should do after coronation. Shaking hands. Lovely service, Vicar. Yeah, exactly.
不，埃德维在前面。所以埃德维是哥哥——哦，对，抱歉，我完全搞乱了——所以爱德华（注：此处指埃德维）于956年在泰晤士河畔金斯敦加冕，那几乎是在埃德（埃德加）后来在巴斯加冕的20年前。根据邓斯坦的传记，他表现得非常非常糟糕——所以他加冕了，是的——而且他没有闲逛，你知道的，去做一个国王在加冕后应该做的事。握手。美好的仪式，牧师。是的，完全如此。
He goes off and has a threesome. Oh, no, Tom. Who with? With a very well-born lady and her adult daughter is the... A mother and daughter threesome. A mother and daughter threesome. And the story is that he goes off and there's much embarrassment.
他走出去搞3P了。哦，不，汤姆。和谁？和一个出身名门的贵妇以及她成年女儿是……一个母亲和女儿的3P。一个母亲和女儿的3P。故事是这样的，他走开了，这非常尴尬。
And so Dunstan and his relative, who's the Bishop of Lichfield, are the only ones brave enough to go and find out what's happened. And they go in and apparently Edwige has thrown the crown off. And this is actually the first mention of a crown in English history.
所以邓斯坦和他的亲戚——利奇菲尔德的主教——是仅有的几个有勇气去查明发生了什么的人。他们走了进去，显然埃德维把王冠扔了。这其实是英国历史上对王冠的首次记载。
Oh, how embarrassing for England. Yeah. And he's embarrassing for England. Yeah. And he's tossed it onto the ground. And meanwhile, according to the hagiographer, Edwige was disporting himself disgracefully between the two women as though they were wallowing in some revolting pigsty. Oh, my word. And Dunstan basically comes in and bollocks him and says, pull yourself together and kind of hauls Edwige off. If that happens at the weekend i will be astounded so but but the likelihood is is that this is pro dunstan and edgar
哦，对英格兰来说太尴尬了。是的。这为英格兰抹黑了。是的。他把它扔到了地上。与此同时，根据圣徒传记作家的说法，埃德维在两个女人之间表现得极其下流，就像在某个令人作呕的猪圈里打滚一样。哦，天哪。邓斯坦基本上走了进去，痛骂了他一顿，告诉他振作起来，并把埃德维粗暴地拉走了。如果这在周末发生，我会大吃一惊的，所以——但可能性是，这是亲邓斯坦和埃德加的
propaganda because almost certainly the adult daughter is the woman who edwy actually married of gifu who is his wife so it seems harsh and a reminder of the fact that the kind of the the harsh stories that can be told of coronations do often reflect a bias and often can be back projected as well. So there's a third coronation that Dunstan was involved in, which is the coronation of Edgar's son, Æthelred, who comes to be called Æthelred the Unready. Notoriously a terrible reign. Dunstan prayed that Ethelred be given the faithfulness of Abraham, the meekness of Moses, the courage of Joshua, the humility of David, and the wisdom of Solomon, none of which he particularly seems to have displayed. It was kind of presaged that Ethelred would be terrible because when Dunstan baptized him, Ethelred pissed into the font. So this happens a lot in coronation stories. So when you get to the Stuarts, people say,
宣传，因为几乎可以肯定，那个成年女儿就是埃德维实际娶的女人——奥吉夫，也就是他的妻子。所以这看起来很严厉，也提醒了我们这样一个事实：关于加冕典礼的严厉故事往往反映了一种偏见，而且往往也可以被事后投射。所以邓斯坦还参与了第三次加冕典礼，那就是埃德加的儿子埃塞尔雷德的加冕典礼，他后来被称为无准备者埃塞尔雷德。出了名糟糕的统治。邓斯坦祈祷埃塞尔雷德能拥有亚伯拉罕的忠诚、摩西的温顺、约书亚的勇气、大卫的谦逊以及所罗门的智慧，然而他似乎并没有表现出其中任何一点。埃塞尔雷德注定会很糟糕，因为当邓斯坦给他施洗时，埃塞尔雷德尿在了洗礼盘里。所以这在加冕故事中经常发生。所以当你到了斯图亚特王朝时，人们会说，
oh, there were dreadful omens about coronation. This such and such went wrong. But as we'll see, something goes wrong in most coronations. People don't turn up or they forget the crown or whatever. I mean, again, maybe when we come to look at Shakespeare and how Shakespeare looks at coronations, this idea that the fate of the king is joined to the fate of the country is still very strong by the late Tudor early Stuart period. So very important idea. So I suppose one thing with medieval coronations is that we actually don't know very much about most of them, do we? Because the sources are so scant. So the one that always sticks out in my mind, Tom, and you'll tell me whether this is an accurate description or not, is William I,
哦，关于加冕典礼有可怕的预兆。这个那个出了问题。但正如我们将看到的，大多数加冕典礼中都会出问题。人们没有出现，或者他们忘记了王冠什么的。我的意思是，同样，也许当我们来看莎士比亚以及莎士比亚如何看待加冕典礼时，这种“国王的命运与国家的命运息息相关”的思想在都铎王朝晚期到斯图亚特王朝早期依然非常强烈。这是一个非常重要的想法。所以我想关于中世纪加冕典礼的一点是，实际上我们对大多数加冕典礼知之甚少，不是吗？因为史料太匮乏了。所以总是在我脑海中挥之不去的一个，汤姆，你会告诉我这是否是一个准确的描述，那就是威廉一世，
where basically everybody dies. William the Conqueror. Is that fair? Not everybody, but it doesn't go tremendously well because it's held in westminster abbey yeah you know the great abbey built by edward the confessor that we talked about in the first episode the king is hailed with kind of vivat you know long live the king the norman soldiers who are outside assume that a riot has broken outside in the abbey and for reasons that aren't entirely clear they respond to this by rushing around setting fire to the rest of london which which is quite quite odd behavior yeah and everybody sees you know that houses and shops are on fire so they all rush in and start looting it the whole thing is a disaster
基本上所有人都死了。征服者威廉。这公平吗？并不是所有人都死了，但它进行得并不顺利，因为它是在威斯敏斯特修道院举行的，是的，你知道由忏悔者爱德华建造的大修道院，我们在第一集里讨论过。国王在“万岁”（拉丁语 Vivat，意为国王万岁）声中受到欢呼，在修道院外面的诺曼士兵误以为修道院外爆发了骚乱，出于并不完全清楚的原因，他们对此的反应是冲来冲去，放火烧毁了伦敦的其他地方，这相当——相当奇怪的行为，是的，每个人都看到房子和商店着火了，所以他们都冲进去开始抢劫，整件事成了一场灾难。
yeah and what's interesting about this account it's so it's um by an english chronicler called alderic vitalis he notes that the monks and the bishops who are doing the coronation, they stay in the abbey, but they're kind of very nervous. And the other person who's very nervous is William, who trembles throughout the whole thing. But that's not surprising. He's in a foreign country. He's beaten King Harold at Hastings.
是的，这段记载有趣的地方在于，它是——嗯，是由一位名叫奥德里克·维塔利斯的英国编年史家写的。他指出，主持加冕典礼的修士和主教们留在了修道院里，但他们非常紧张。另一个非常紧张的人是威廉，他在整个过程中都在发抖。但这并不奇怪。他在一个异国他乡。他在黑斯廷斯击败了哈罗德国王。
He's insecure, right? Which is why there are so many soldiers, guards there at all. But it's possible as well that he's trembling because he is nervous about whether God is truly blessing him, that maybe the disaster of the consecration is something that may reflect God's wrath. And that really matters to William because one of the reasons why he has so wanted to become King of England is that the consecration and anointing obviously raises him to a level almost equal to that of the King of France. And so a century later, a canon lawyer writing in Bologna will note that properly
他缺乏安全感，对吧？这就是为什么那里有那么多的士兵和卫兵。但也有可能他发抖是因为他担心上帝是否真的在保佑他，也许加冕礼的灾难可能反映了上帝的愤怒。这对威廉来说真的很重要，因为他如此渴望成为英格兰国王的原因之一是，加冕和受膏显然将他的地位提升到了几乎与法国国王相等的水平。因此，一个世纪后，一位在博洛尼亚写作的教会法学者会指出，严格来说，
only four kings are anointed at their coronation. So the King of France, King of Jerusalem, King of Sicily, and King of England. And so that is what William is after. And his coronation, to the degree that we can tell, is, I mean, it's drawing on the kind of the Anglo-Saxon rituals that's important because he has to establish his legitimacy as an English king, but it's also very kind of imperial. So he's crowned on Christmas day as Charlemagne had been crowned. His crown is inspired by Byzantine examples. So you remember those kind of dinky little crowns the Byzantine emperors have with the pearls that kind of hang down by their cheeks. And the order
只有四位国王在加冕时受膏。即法国国王、耶路撒冷国王、西西里国王和英格兰国王。这就是威廉所追求的。他的加冕典礼，就我们所能了解的程度而言，我的意思是，它借鉴了盎格鲁-撒克逊的仪式，这很重要，因为他必须确立自己作为英国国王的合法性，但它也非常具有帝国色彩。所以他在圣诞节那天加冕，就像查理曼大帝加冕一样。他的王冠灵感来自拜占庭的样式。所以你还记得拜占庭皇帝戴的那种小巧玲珑的王冠，上面有珍珠垂在脸颊旁。加冕典礼的
of service is read in French as well as in English. So for William, the coronation is setting the seal on his great victory. And therefore, the fact that it doesn't go tremendously well, you can understand why it would be a cause of anxiety to him. Yes, absolutely. We don't know much about the coronations of William I's successors or some of the Plantagenets, but there's a slight sense of downplaying coronations at this point. Well, so this is by the papacy. Going into the 11th century, this is the period of the Gregorian revolution when the papacy and the church more generally is trying to stop kings from identifying themselves with a kind of sacral role. They're trying to get rid of the idea that a king might have a priestly status. Priests are priests, secular rulers are secular
仪式顺序是用法语和英语宣读的。因此，对威廉来说，加冕典礼为他的伟大胜利盖上了印章。因此，它进行得并不顺利这一事实，你可以理解为什么这会成为他焦虑的根源。是的，绝对的。我们对威廉一世的继承人或某些金雀花王朝国王的加冕典礼知之甚少，但在此时有一种淡化加冕典礼的轻微感觉。嗯，这是由教皇制定的。进入11世纪，这是格里高利改革时期，当时教皇制和整个教会都在试图阻止国王将自己与某种神圣角色等同起来。他们试图消除国王可能具有祭司地位的想法。祭司是祭司，世俗统治者是世俗
rulers, and the division between them must be very secure. And so this is a period when the church starts trying to stop kings from being anointed with chrism, which is this kind of awesome oil which can supposedly calm the sea and make fields fertile. And they start kind of proclaiming kings that they're kings by the grace of God, which is therefore to kind of heighten the role that is played by the bishop or by the archbishop. So it emphasises the role played by the church in all this. Kings by and large go with this chiefly because they're kind of forced to. So Henry II, who at his coronation had insisted in being proclaimed in very, very grandiose terms,
统治者，两者之间的界限必须非常牢固。因此，这是教会开始试图阻止国王用圣油（chrism）受膏的时期，这是一种据说可以平息海洋并使田地肥沃的可怕油脂。他们开始宣称国王是承蒙上帝恩典的国王，这因此提高了主教或大主教所扮演的角色。因此，它强调了教会在此事中所扮演的角色。国王大体上接受这一点，主要是因为他们被迫这么做。因此，亨利二世在加冕时曾坚持以非常非常宏大的词藻来宣布自己，
then blots his copy book by having Thomas Becket killed. And so essentially has to kind of see terms. Henry II's sons, Richard I and John, both have calamitous coronations. Oh no, what happens? Well, so Richard I's coronation, there's another riot because there are Jews in the audience outside Westminster Abbey and they try to come in and this precipitates a massive riot. And once again all the houses of London get set on fire.
却因下令杀害托马斯·贝克特而玷污了自己的名声。因此基本上不得不去妥协。亨利二世的儿子们，理查一世和约翰，都经历了灾难性的加冕典礼。哦，不，发生了什么？嗯，所以理查一世的加冕典礼上又发生了一场骚乱，因为威斯敏斯特修道院外有犹太人在场，他们试图进来，这引发了一场大规模的骚乱。伦敦的所有房屋再次被放火烧毁。
So there's no kind of multi-faith stuff with Richard I. And John disgraces himself by laughing throughout the entire coronation. Laughing out of nerves? Who knows? I mean, that's the story. A sort of Kendall Roy figure. Yeah, very much Kendall Roy, yes. Yes.
所以在理查一世身上没有什么跨信仰的东西。而约翰则在整个加冕典礼期间一直在笑，以此来 disgraces 自己（自取其辱）。因为紧张而笑？谁知道呢？我的意思是，故事就是这样的。一种肯德尔·罗伊式的人物。是的，非常像肯德尔·罗伊，是的。是的。
And again, probably a back projection. People looking at his disastrous reign and saying it was kind of presage. Right. One of the things that's really striking about the relationship of kings to their coronation is that it's often the kings who are in the weakest position, who are understandably keenest on making the coronation as grand and imposing as possible. So John's reign is so disastrous that he ends up losing all the crown jewels in the wash. And then he dies, leaving his son, Henry, who was only nine
而且，这可能也是一种事后投射。人们看着他灾难性的统治，说这是预示。对。关于国王与加冕典礼的关系，最引人注目的事情之一是，往往是那些处于最弱地位的国王，他们理所当然地最热衷于让加冕典礼尽可能宏大和雄伟。所以约翰的统治是如此灾难性，以至于他最终在洗劫中丢失了所有的王冠珠宝。然后他死了，留下他的儿子亨利，当他成为国王时年仅九岁。
years old when he becomes king. And he can't go and be crowned in Westminster Abbey because it's occupied by the French, who have sent over the Dauphin Louis to become king. And for a while, it looks as though abey of Gloucester that will in due course become the Cathedral of Gloucester. And because John has lost all the crown jewels, Henry III has to be crowned with his mother's crown. Oh my word. So in every respect, this is not a great coronation. It's not a great coronation. And Henry is so upset by this that he asked for a papal dispensation when in due course the whole of England has been recaptured and he is undisputed king of England. He asked for a special papal dispensation to be crowned and anointed again in Westminster Abbey. So he had two coronations?
他不能去威斯敏斯特修道院加冕，因为它被法国人占领了，法国人派了路易王太子来当国王。有一段时间，看起来似乎——格洛斯特修道院，它日后将成为格洛斯特大教堂。由于约翰弄丢了所有的王冠珠宝，亨利三世不得不戴着他母亲的王冠加冕。哦，天哪。所以无论从哪个方面来看，这都不是一次伟大的加冕典礼。这不是一次伟大的加冕典礼。亨利对此感到非常沮丧，以至于当整个英格兰最终被收复、他成为无可争议的英格兰国王时，他请求获得教皇的特许。他请求获得一项特殊的教皇特许，以便再次在威斯敏斯特修道院加冕和受膏。所以他有过两次加冕典礼？
He had two coronations, yeah. A bit like Charles II had, as we'll discover, he had two coronations, didn't he? The first three Stuarts, they're the kings of Scotland as well as England, and so they're crowned in Scotland as well as England. This is slightly different because by and large, you can't have two anointings because the anointing is so, I mean, it's so freighted with holiness that you can't do it twice. But Henry does get this special dispensation. And having been crowned in Westminster Abbey, he then redevelops it. So it's Henry III who basically builds the Abbey as it stands now and is clearly very keen that he have a stage commensurate with the grandeur of his position, having been so close to total ruin.
他有过两次加冕典礼，是的。有点像查理二世，正如我们将会发现的，他也有过两次加冕典礼，不是吗？前三位斯图亚特国王，他们既是苏格兰国王又是英格兰国王，所以他们在苏格兰和英格兰都加冕了。这有点不同，因为大体上你不能接受两次受膏，因为受膏太——我的意思是，它充满了神圣性，你不能做两次。但亨利确实得到了这个特殊的特许。在威斯敏斯特修道院加冕后，他又对其进行了重新开发。所以基本上是亨利三世建造了现在这个样子的修道院，并且显然非常渴望拥有一个与其地位的宏大相匹配的舞台，毕竟他曾如此接近彻底的毁灭。
So after Henry III, pretty much all his successes, I think I'm right in saying with it, just a couple of exceptions are crowned in Westminster Abbey, aren't they? Right. So Edward V, who's one of the princes in the Tower, he doesn't because he gets killed. Yes. they? Right. So Edward V, who's one of the princes in the tower, he doesn't because he gets killed. And Edward VIII doesn't because he abdicates before he becomes king, but all the others get crowned in Westminster Abbey. But what happens with, for example, so Richard II, he's a Plantagenet, but he's booted out by Henry IV, who is a usurper. So presumably his coronation is a pretty big deal for him because he needs to assert his legitimacy. They start to invent various stories that kind of serve to leverage the awesome quality of the ritual that is being performed at the coronation. So Henry IV is anointed with an oil that supposedly, well, it's the subject of a prophecy by Thomas Beckett, the martyred Archbishop of Canterbury.
所以在亨利三世之后，几乎他所有的继承人——我想我说得对的话，除了少数几个例外——都是在威斯敏斯特修道院加冕的，对吧？对。所以爱德华五世，塔中王子之一，他没有，因为他被杀了。是的。他们？对。所以爱德华五世，塔中王子的其中之一，他没有，因为他被杀了。爱德华八世也没有，因为他在成为国王之前就退位了，但所有其他人都在威斯敏斯特修道院加冕。但是，比如说，理查二世，他是金雀花王朝的人，但他被篡位者亨利四世赶下台了。所以对亨利四世来说，他的加冕典礼大概是一件相当大的事，因为他需要确立自己的合法性。他们开始编造各种故事，这些故事某种程度上用来借力于加冕典礼上所进行的仪式的可怕威力。因此，亨利四世是用一种油受膏的，这种油据说——嗯，它是坎特伯雷殉道大主教托马斯·贝克特的一个预言的主题。
Who I played on stage. Yes. The Virgin Mary had appeared to him while he was in exile, kind of hiding from Henry II, and presented him with this eagle, eagle made of gold. And inside there was a stone flask and it was filled with this incredibly holy oil. And the Virgin told Thomas that at some future point, this oil would be used for a wonderful new king who would be coming. This is the oil that is used in the coronation of Henry IV. So it's this idea that Henry IV isn't a usurper at all. He is the fulfillment of a prophecy by Aragorn or something. Right. Because if he's got this fancy oil, that's definitely a sign that he's legitimate. And then with Henry V, this story gets kind of
我在舞台上扮演过他。是的。圣母玛利亚在他流亡期间（当时他正躲避亨利二世）曾向他显现，并把这只鹰——金鹰——交给了他。里面有一个石制的烧瓶，里面装满了这种极其神圣的油。圣母告诉托马斯，在未来的某个时候，这种油将被用于一个即将到来的奇妙的新国王。这就是亨利四世加冕典礼上使用的油。所以这就是这种想法：亨利四世根本不是篡位者。他是阿拉贡人（注：指《指环王》中的阿拉贡）或其他什么人预言的实现。对。因为如果他有这种奇特的油，那绝对是他合法的标志。然后到了亨利五世，这个故事被进一步
elaborated and it gets said that, furthermore, the king who will be anointed with this holy oil of St. Thomas will go on to reconquer Normandy and Aquitaine, which is what Henry V then goes on to do. So fancy that. Who would have thought that? So this story is definitely true. I mean, undoubtedly. So I think you can absolutely see there that kings who feel that the foundations of their power are unstable really enjoy beefing up coronation rituals and stories to try and solidify their sense of legitimacy. But then what do you do, Tom, when you have a king who can't even speak? So Henry VI, who succeeds Henry V in 1422, he is 10 months old. How do they crown him? Yeah, well, and adding to that problem is the fact that things start to go quite badly in France. So Henry VI is the son of Henry V and the daughter of Charles VI of France. And Henry V and Charles VI both die
细化了，据说此外，这位用圣托马斯的圣油受膏的国王将继续重新征服诺曼底和阿基坦，而这正是亨利五世接下来所做的。所以想象一下。谁能想到呢？所以这个故事绝对是真的。我的意思是，毫无疑问。所以我想你绝对可以看出，那些觉得自己权力基础不稳固的国王真的很喜欢加强加冕仪式和故事，试图巩固他们的合法感。但是汤姆，当你有一个甚至不会说话的国王时，你会怎么做呢？所以亨利六世，在1422年继承亨利五世，他只有10个月大。他们怎么给他加冕？是的，好吧，雪上加霜的是法国的局势开始变得非常糟糕。所以亨利六世是亨利五世和法国查理六世的女儿的儿子。亨利五世和查理六世都在1422年去世，
in 1422, which means that by virtue of the treaty that Henry V and Charles VI had signed, Henry VI is king by right of both England and France. But Charles VI has a son, the Dauphin, Charles VII, who has been delegitimized. But a lot of people in France want him to be king. And famously among the people who want him to be king is Joan of Arc. And so she leads him deep into enemy territory, crowns him in the traditional site of coronations in France, and then kind of takes him back to continue the fight. And that means that the English government in France obviously needs to trump this in an urgent manner. And so they get the very young Henry VI, who by this point must be what, about six, I think, maybe eight. I mean, he's still a very young boy.
这意味着根据亨利五世和查理六世签署的条约，亨利六世是享有英格兰和法国双重国王权利的国王。但查理六世有一个儿子，即王太子查理七世，他已经被剥夺了合法性。但法国的许多人希望他成为国王。其中最著名的希望他成为国王的人就是圣女贞德。于是她带领他深入敌后，在法国传统的加冕地点为他加冕，然后把他带回来继续战斗。这意味着法国的英国政府显然需要紧急超越这一点。于是他们把年幼的亨利六世弄到了法国，当时他大概有多大，大约六岁吧，我想，也许八岁。我的意思是，他仍然是个小男孩。
Or even seven. he crosses over to France. He hangs out in France for a fair amount of time. And then at the end of 1431, he basically gets smuggled into Paris, gets crowned in Notre Dame, and hurrah, hurrah, he's the king of France. So a French coronation held by an English king. Yes. Surrounded presumably by English soldiers. And also crowned by his great uncle, who is a cardinal, but very English. Right. And so that doesn't go down well. And what ultimately blots Henry VI's copybook is that the feast that is held to celebrate his coronation, all the French complain about the quality of English cooking, which is...
甚至七岁。他去了法国。他在法国呆了相当长的一段时间。然后在1431年底，他基本上被偷运进巴黎，在巴黎圣母院加冕，万岁，万岁，他是法国国王了。所以这是一个由英国国王举办的法国加冕典礼。是的。周围大概都是英国士兵。而且是由他的大叔加冕的，他是一位枢机主教，但非常英国化。对。所以这并不受欢迎。最终玷污亨利六世名声的是，为庆祝他的加冕典礼而举办的宴会上，所有法国人都抱怨英国烹饪的质量，那是……
Oh my gosh. It's terrible that nationalistic prejudice can come into things like this, isn't it, Tom? So Henry VI is the only king to have been formally crowned and anointed as king, both of France and of England, in two separate and distinct ceremonies. And his reign goes on to be absolutely disastrous. So it kind of precipitates the Wars of the Roses. You have Yorkists and Lancastrians and Lancastrians and Yorkists all busily succeeding each other. Again, you see this process whereby it's usurpers who have to emphasize in their coronations just how potent a ritual is being staged. So when Henry VII, the first Tudors, defeats Richard III at Bosworth, the last Yorkist king,
噢，天哪。民族主义偏见竟然能介入这种事情，真是太可怕了，对吧，汤姆？所以亨利六世是唯一一位在两个独立且不同的仪式中被正式加冕并受膏为法国国王和英格兰国王的国王。而他的统治后来变得绝对灾难性。所以它某种程度上引发了玫瑰战争。约克家族和兰开斯特家族，兰开斯特家族和约克家族都在忙着彼此更迭。再次，你看到了这个过程：篡位者必须在他们的加冕典礼上强调正在上演的仪式是多么强大。因此，当都铎王朝的第一位国王亨利七世在博斯沃思击败最后一位约克王朝国王理查三世时，
and he goes to London and he meets with his mother, Lady Margaret Beaufort, for the first time in 14 years at his coronation. So it must have been a very emotional occasion for them all. A very high pressure occasion, yeah. According to the Bishop of Rochester, who was her confessor, when she saw Henry being crowned, when the king was crowned in all that great triumph and glory, she wept marvelously. But she might also have been very impressed by the crown that Henry chooses to be crowned with, which is an imperial crown. And an imperial crown, Dominic, is the kind of crown that has arches that go up from the coronet and an orb on the top. And these are called imperial crowns because these arches are symbolic of a rule of an empire. So you're enclosing all the world.
他来到伦敦，在加冕典礼上14年来第一次见到了他的母亲玛格丽特·博福特夫人。对他们所有人来说，这一定是一个非常情绪化的时刻。一个高压的时刻，是的。根据身为她告解神父的罗切斯特主教所说，当她看到亨利加冕时，当国王在所有的伟大凯旋和荣耀中加冕时，她惊奇地哭了。但她也可能对亨利选择加冕的王冠印象深刻，那是一顶帝国王冠。多米尼克，帝国王冠就是那种从冠冕向上延伸出拱形结构并在顶部有一个宝球的王冠。这些被称为帝国王冠，因为这些拱形代表着对帝国的统治。所以你要把全世界都包围起来。
Enclosing all the world and mounted by the orb, which symbolizes the world. So it's Henry VII who has himself crowned imperially. But of course, it's his son, Henry VIII, who initiates the Reformation and declares England an empire. Yeah. and declares England an empire. The Pope has no jurisdiction over England, who sets the monarchy, the country, and the coronation ritual on a kind of slalom ride, a rollercoaster ride, what I might say. Slalom ride. Kind of veering all over the place, ideologically.
把全世界都包围起来，并以象征世界的宝球为顶。所以是亨利七世让自己以帝国的方式加冕。但当然，是他的儿子亨利八世开启了宗教改革并宣布英格兰为一个帝国。是的。并宣布英格兰为一个帝国。教皇对英格兰没有管辖权，他将君主制、国家和加冕仪式带入了一种回旋滑雪般的过山车式的旅程，我可能会这么说。回旋滑雪般的旅程。在意识形态上到处摇摆不定。
Those are two very different things, a rollercoaster and a slalom. You know what I mean. Okay. I do know what you mean. Well, Henry VIII's coronation would just do that because it's the last pre-Reformation coronation, isn't it? So that's 1509. We do have descriptions of that. So the closer we get in time to the present day, the more lavish the descriptions of coronation. So we know that Henry VIII, so he's married Catherine of Aragon. He's decided to marry her just beforehand because he needs a bride straight away. So it's the coronation of the two of them. With all these coronations, they have this great parade
那是两件非常不同的事情，过山车和回旋滑雪。你知道我的意思。好吧。我确实知道你的意思。好吧，亨利八世的加冕典礼就会那样做，因为它是最后一次宗教改革前的加冕典礼，不是吗？那是1509年。我们确实有关于那次加冕的描述。所以我们距离现代越近，对加冕典礼的描述就越豪华。所以我们知道亨利八世——他娶了阿拉贡的凯瑟琳。他决定在此之前不久娶她，因为他急需一个新娘。所以这是他们两人的加冕典礼。在所有的这些加冕典礼中，他们有一天在伦敦街头举行盛大的游行，
through the streets of London on one day, and then the coronation is on the next. And it's a kind of doubleheader for the spectators. Actually, it's the parade and the procession and the pageants and the stalls and the plays and the songs and all that stuff. The mumming, exactly. It's just as exciting. The tremendous robes and all of this sort of stuff.
然后第二天举行加冕典礼。对观众来说，这是一个双重节目。实际上，这是游行、行进、盛装表演、摊位、戏剧、歌曲以及所有这些东西。滑稽剧，没错。同样令人兴奋。巨大的长袍以及所有这类东西。
They have it on a midsummer Sunday, the actual coronation. So it's perfectly timed. And he's very much a Renaissance prince at that point, isn't he? Dashing and slim and playing the lute and jousting.
他们在仲夏的一个星期日举行实际的加冕典礼。所以时间安排得非常完美。而且他当时非常像一个文艺复兴时期的王子，不是吗？意气风发、身材苗条、弹奏着琵琶还参加马上长矛比武。
Exactly. So Margaret Beaufort is still there. So that's his grandmother. And she's there, you know, wiping her eyes. Obviously, everything's gone tremendously well for the Tudors. we know the oath that he swears with goodwill and devout soul I promise I shall keep privilege of the law canon and of holy church and I shall by God's grace defend
没错。所以玛格丽特·博福特还在那里。那是他的祖母。她也在那里，你知道的，擦着眼泪。显然，都铎王朝的一切都进展得非常顺利。我们知道他宣誓的誓言：“我将怀着善意和虔诚的灵魂承诺，我将维护教会法和圣教会的特权，并且我将借着上帝的恩典保卫
you and each one of you bishops and abbots through my realm blah blah blah well that turned out well didn't it well exactly the nice irony there but that's going back to what you were saying in our first podcast about the importance of the oath and the idea of the king as the servant of his people. Then they leave, Henry and Catherine, they go and have this tremendous banquet and they have festivities for days. And we've got a nice little moment which anticipates so many moments to come. People are very excited and they go and they tear up the carpet.
你和你领地内的每一位主教和修道院院长，等等等等。”嗯，结果证明这很好，不是吗？嗯，确实，这里有一个很好的讽刺，但这回到了我们在第一播客中谈到的关于誓言的重要性以及国王作为其人民仆人的想法。然后他们离开，亨利和凯瑟琳去举行了一场盛大的宴会，并庆祝了好几天。我们有一个美好的小插曲，预示了未来许多时刻的到来。人们非常兴奋，他们去把地毯撕碎了。
So there's a huge scarlet runner kind of carpet and people go and rip out bits of the carpet as souvenirs. Nice. I was wondering why they were ripping the carpet up, but that makes perfect sense.
所以有一条巨大的红色赛跑式地毯，人们去扯下地毯的碎片作为纪念品。太棒了。我一直在想他们为什么要撕地毯，但这就完全说得通了。
I don't know whether any of those bits still survive. One last thing about Henry VIII. Henry VIII also does something very unusual. He has Anne Boleyn crowned in 1533. Why is that unusual? I thought queens were being crowned. Yeah, but normally you don't then marry a queen later on. Oh, I see. Of course. Yes. So
我不知道这些碎片是否还有幸存下来的。关于亨利八世的最后一件事。亨利八世还做了一件非常不寻常的事。他在1533年为安妮·博林加冕。为什么这不寻常？我以为女王都要加冕的。是的，但通常你不会在后来又去娶一个女王。哦，我明白了。当然。是的。所以
she's crowned separately. Yes. So she has a separate coronation. Now that doesn't normally happen. She has a separate coronation presided over by Thomas Cranmer. So the reformation is now underway, the break with Rome. With hilarious consequences. Well, not hilarious for Anne Boleyn, because unlike with Catherine of Aragon, where everyone was delighted to see Catherine of Aragon, they're very displeased to see Anne Boleyn. And she complains to Henry afterwards and says, Nobody cheered.
她是被单独加冕的。是的。所以她有一个单独的加冕典礼。这通常不会发生。她有一个由托马斯·克兰默主持的独立加冕典礼。所以宗教改革现在正在进行中，与罗马决裂。伴随着滑稽的后果。嗯，对安妮·博林来说一点也不滑稽，因为与阿拉贡的凯瑟琳不同，当时每个人都高兴看到阿拉贡的凯瑟琳，而他们看到安妮·博林时非常不高兴。她事后向亨利抱怨说：“没有人欢呼。”
No, not enough cheers. And we all know what happened to her, Tom. Nothing good. Nothing good. So let's come back after the break and do more Tudor coronations. Then we get into the Stuarts and it all really starts to kick off. Brilliant. Look forward to that.
不，欢呼声不够。我们都知道她后来怎么样了，汤姆。没有什么好下场。没有什么好下场。所以我们休息一下后回来，讲讲更多的都铎王朝加冕典礼。然后我们进入斯图亚特王朝，事情就真的开始变得热闹起来了。太棒了。拭目以待。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《历史的 Rest》之娱乐篇。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量秀场八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to our coronation-themed romp through centuries of English history. And we have reached the 16th century, the Tudors, and more specifically, the Reformation, which is all about kicking out popery and superstition and idolatry and nonsense and ritual and all that kind of thing, as
如果你想要无广告广播、加赠剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们以加冕典礼为主题的英国数百年历史漫游。我们已经来到了16世纪的都铎王朝，更具体地说，是宗教改革，这完全是为了驱逐天主教、迷信、偶像崇拜、废话、仪式以及诸如此类的事情，正如
Protestants would put it. I suppose one of the things that's interesting about when Edward VIII dies and is succeeded by his very young son, Edward VI, is that nobody thinks, well, should we get rid of the coronation? Isn't the coronation with all its anointings and its bowing before the altar and things, isn't this all just kind of papist mummery? No, they don't think that, do they? Well, I suppose you have to have some form of inauguration of the new monarch, don't you? But there are, absolutely, there are Protestants, radical Protestants, who argue that it's all idolatry and clearly standing at the head of a tradition that is still very much alive today, which would absolutely say, well,
新教徒所说的那样。我想，当爱德华八世（注：此处疑为主持人口误，指爱德华六世）去世并由他非常年幼的儿子爱德华六世继承时，有趣的一点是，没有人会想：我们是不是应该取消加冕典礼？加冕典礼连同其所有的涂油礼、在圣坛前的鞠躬等，难道不全都是天主教的假把式吗？不，他们不这么认为，是吗？嗯，我想你必须对新君主有一定的就职仪式，不是吗？但确实有，绝对有新教徒，激进的新教徒，他们认为这全都是偶像崇拜，并且显然站在今天仍然非常活跃的传统的最前沿，他们绝对会说，
should we be spending money on coronations when we can give it to the poor? And isn't this all just nonsense? You know my views of that, Tom. Well, Edward VI has a slimmed-down coronation, to be fair. Not quite Scandinavian bicycling monarchy, but... Well, they're worried, aren't they, that he'll get too tired? that tom um well hedward the sixth has a slim down coronation to be fair not quite scandinavian bicycling monarchy but well they're worried aren't they that he'll get too tired but he's any what is he nine they admit themselves at this point it's the first time i think you can find somebody
我们本可以把钱给穷人，为什么还要把它花在加冕典礼上呢？这难道不是一派胡言吗？你知道我对这事的看法，汤姆。嗯，公平地说，爱德华六世有一个精简版的加冕典礼。不能算斯堪的纳维亚式的骑自行车君主制，但是……嗯，他们担心，不是吗，他会太累？那，汤姆——嗯，公平地说，爱德华六世有一个精简版的加冕典礼。不能算斯堪的纳维亚式的骑自行车君主制，但是……嗯，他们担心，不是吗，他会太累？但他几岁了——他九岁。他们自己也承认，此时这是我第一次发现有人
admitting that coronation actually can be quite boring yeah well richard the second who was also young when he got ground he fell asleep in his right so they say because of the tedious length which would weary and be hurtsome to the king's majesty being yet of tender age, they should cut it down from 12 hours to seven hours. Imagine that, a 12 hour. by a man from the nation of Aragon, an acrobat, who slides down a tightrope from the steeple of St. Paul's Cathedral as swiftly as if he had been a bird. Oh, we were talking about roller coasters. I'd like to see more acrobatics at the King's Coronation. And this is the backdrop to Mark Twain's novel,
承认加冕典礼其实会相当无通道（枯燥）——是的，理查二世登基时也很年轻，他在——对，所以他们说因为那冗长乏味的时长会让正处幼年的国王陛下感到厌烦和受损，所以他们应该把12个小时缩减到7个小时。想象一下，12个小时。由一个来自阿拉贡国家的人，一个杂技演员，像一只鸟一样迅捷地从圣保罗大教堂的尖顶顺着紧绷的绳索滑下来。哦，我们刚才在谈论过山车。我希望在国王的加冕典礼上看到更多杂技。这就是马克·吐温小说《
The Prince and the Paupers. Tom Carty, is that the name of the character? Tom Canty. Where the pauper and the prince and the prince they kind of look alike and swap places yeah they do indeed but of course what would fascinate you about this tom is that it's the first protestant coronation yes so they get rid of lots of sort of rituals and stuff like that there's lots of talk of idolatry and tyranny and superstition. But, I mean, Edward is laid on the altar for his anointing and Cranmer anoints him on the back
王子与贫儿》的背景。汤姆·卡蒂，那是那个角色的名字吗？汤姆·康蒂。贫儿和王子，王子他们长得很像并且互换了身份，是的，他们的确如此。当然，汤姆，最让你着迷的是，这是第一次新教徒的加冕典礼，是的，所以他们摆脱了许多类似仪式的东西，有很多关于偶像崇拜、暴政和迷信的讨论。但是，我的意思是，爱德华被放在圣坛上接受涂油，克兰默在他的背上涂油，
and he takes the oath on the sacrament. So there's still kind of hangovers. But doesn't Cranmer say to him, you're God's vice regents and Christ's vicar. So you're the big man. Yes. And there's a strong implication that, well, it's not an implication.
并且他在圣礼上宣誓。所以仍然有一些残留。但是克兰默对他说：你是上帝的摄政王和基督的副主教。所以你是大人物。是的。这里有一个强烈的暗示，或者说这不是暗示。
I mean, it's stated that the anointing is not to sacralize the young king. It's not to kind of make him, you know, to dignify him, give him a new dignity that he wouldn't otherwise have. It's just something that's done to him because he already has this power by virtue of descent. Oh, that's interesting. It's a kind of subtle shift. So essentially, it's about the focus of the ritual is changed from the idea of a king as a kind of priestly figure to king as absolutely a royal figure. So in his sermon, Cranmer says, Edward is a second Josiah. I'm ashamed to admit I don't really know what Josiah did.
我的意思是，明确指出涂油并不是为了使年轻的国王神圣化。它不是为了赋予他某种尊严，赋予他一种原本不会有的新尊严。这只是对他做的一件事，因为他凭借血统已经拥有了这种权力。哦，这很有趣。这是一个微妙的转变。所以本质上，仪式的焦点从“国王作为一种祭司形象”的想法转变为“国王绝对是一个皇室形象”。因此，克兰默在布道中说，爱德华是第二个约西亚。我很羞于承认我其实不知道约西亚做了什么。
So Josiah is the young king who overthrows idols. All right, there you go. Because he says, we look forward to you having the tyranny of the bishops of Rome banished from your subjects and images removed. Yes. Which, of course, then happens, doesn't it? So again, I mean, that's an example of how kings in Christian Europe look to Old Testament kings for exemplars.
所以约西亚是那个推翻偶像的年轻国王。好吧，原来如此。因为他说，我们期待你将罗马主教的暴政从你的臣民中驱逐出去，并移走神像。是的。当然，这随后发生了，不是吗？所以再次说明，这是一个基督教欧洲的国王如何将旧约国王作为榜样的例子。
But of course, Edward doesn't last very long. So in 1553, we have the coronation of Mary, his sister. And now it's a complete turnabout because she is, of course, a Catholic. So she has the sermon. This is given by the Bishop of Chichester, an anchor, George Day. And he had been in prison under Edward VI. He had been in prison for arguing about altars and prayer books. He'd been in the fleet prison.
但当然，爱德华并没有持续多久。所以在1553年，我们迎来了他的姐姐玛丽的加冕典礼。现在这是一个完全的转变，因为她当然是个天主教徒。所以她有布道。这是由奇切斯特主教、一个隐士乔治·戴主持的。他在爱德华六世统治期间曾入狱。他曾因争论圣坛和祈祷书而入狱。他曾在弗利特监狱待过。
Mary lets him out. The Archbishop of Canterbury, Thomas Cranmer, by contrast, is in prison. And will shortly be in a fire. Yes. Will shortly be burned. Exactly. So Mary is anointed not by the Archbishop of Canterbury, but by the Bishop of Winchester. He's a guy called Stephen Gardner, who is the villain in all Tudor dramas.
玛丽放他出来了。相比之下，坎特伯雷大主教托马斯·克兰默则在监狱里。并且很快就会在火堆里。是的。很快就会被烧死。没错。所以玛丽受膏不是由坎特伯雷大主教进行的，而是由温彻斯特主教进行的。他是一个叫斯蒂芬·加德纳的人，他是所有都铎王朝剧集里的反派。
Yes. Isn't he? Because he's sort of quite a Weasley. Well, unless they're written by Catholics. He's always been played by people like Mark Gatiss and things. Yes. Sort of smooth and sinister. Smooth, plausible, and villainous.
是的。难道不是吗？因为他有点像个狡猾的家伙。嗯，除非它们是由天主教徒写的。他总是扮演像马克·加蒂斯那样的人。是的。那种圆滑而阴险。圆滑、巧舌如簧且穷凶极恶。
But there's an issue with oil at Mary's, because the oil that they've got left over from Edward VI, they regard as Protestant oil and therefore not fit for consumption. So they have to order some oil specially. The imperial ambassador orders some oil from the Bishop of Arras. And there was also a big hullabaloo about celebrating mass. It's the absolute centre part of Mary's coronation. Well, it's interesting about the oil, because when in Ducal's Mary dies and gets succeeded by her
但在玛丽的加冕典礼上，油出了问题，因为他们从爱德华六世那里留下的油，被他们视为新教的油，因此不适合使用。所以他们不得不特意订购一些油。帝国大使向阿拉斯主教订购了一些油。关于庆祝弥撒，也有一场大骚乱。这是玛丽加冕典礼的绝对核心部分。嗯，关于油这很有趣，因为当玛丽在日后去世并由她的
sister Elizabeth, who is the daughter of Anne Boleyn and a Protestant, the oil that's used for her is rancid. It's gone off. rancid oil yeah but what is the oil tom this is the key question it's not olive oil obviously surely uh yeah so one of them is under the tudors okay and pulai they are called so they're kind of anointing vessels um so one is full of pure oil and the other is full of chrism which is kind of mixture of olive oil and kind of various elements. What are the elements? Sort of spices or something? Yeah.
妹妹伊丽莎白（安妮·博林的女儿，新教徒）继承时，给她用的油是变质的。它过期了。变质的油，是的。但油到底是什么，汤姆？这是关键问题。当然不是橄榄油，对吧？呃，是的——所以其中一个是在都铎王朝时期，好的，安·博莱（注：此处疑为说话者口误，指用于存放油的安普尔瓶），它们被称为安普尔瓶（ampulla），所以它们是一种涂油器皿——所以一个是满满的纯油，另一个是满满的圣油（chrism），这是一种橄榄油和各种元素的混合物。有哪些元素？某种香料之类的东西？对。
Balm, I think it is. Balms of various kinds. Balms of various kinds. Right. But then in the Stuarts, they mix them together. They kind of create a holy oil cocktail. A metaphor there for the Stuart kingdoms, Tom. Yes, absolutely.
我记得是香脂。各种各样的香脂。各种各样的香脂。对。但在斯图亚特王朝，他们把它们混在一起了。他们创造了一种圣油鸡尾酒。这真是斯图亚特王朝各王国的绝妙隐喻，汤姆。是的，绝对的。
So going back to Elizabeth, I mean, Elizabethabeth also has a the real deal is not so much in some ways the coronation we'll just talk about that in a second but but the processions the day before because they are so stage managed aren't they huge crowds i mean obviously with all the tudors and the stewards because of all the religious ructions and the political kind of controversies of the day it's really important for the regime to assert its legitimacy and to do so in this very, very public, spectacular way. So Elizabeth, for example, she has, I think, there are five pageants that she goes past. So the first one is all about her Englishness, comparing her with her sister's supposed Spanishness. So it harks back to the Wars of
所以回到伊丽莎白，我的意思是，伊丽莎白——重头戏在某种程度上其实不是加冕典礼本身——我们待会儿会谈到那个——而是前一天的游行，因为它们是如此精心策划，不是吗？庞大的群众，我的意思是，显然所有的都铎王朝和斯图亚特王朝，由于当时所有的宗教冲突和政治争议，对政权来说，以这种非常公开、壮观的方式来宣示其合法性是非常重要的。所以伊丽莎白，例如，她有，我想，有五场大型盛装游行。所以第一场完全是关于她的英国血统，将她与她姐姐所谓的西班牙血统进行对比。所以这可以追溯到战争时期
the Roses and has a sort of tableau of her descent. The second one shows her the four virtues of true religion, love of subjects, wisdom and justice. And true religion is symbolized by the Bible, isn't it? By the Protestant religion, exactly. They're trampling on superstition and ignorance. And as you say, at one point there's a figure of truth carrying a Bible written in English. And actually truth presents the Bible to Elizabeth as she passes, and she kisses it, and all the crowd cheer and say, you know, hurrah for the true faith, all this kind of thing.
玫瑰战争，里面展示了她家世渊源的一幅画面。第二幅画展示了真正宗教的四种美德：对臣民的爱、智慧和正义。真正的宗教由《圣经》象征，对吧？准确地说，是新教。他们在践踏迷信和无知。正如你所说，在某个时刻，出现了一个真理的形象，手里拿着一本用英文写的《圣经》。实际上，真理在伊丽莎白经过时把《圣经》呈献给她，她吻了它，所有的人群都欢呼并说，你知道的，为真正的信仰万岁，诸如此类的事情。
Throwing their caps in the air. Throwing their caps in the air, as presumably they've been paid to do. I mean, that's the thing with all these. I mean, the interesting thing, contrasting that with the coronation, is that we don't know very much about the coronation. And there's some confusion as to exactly what the status of Catholic rituals, what's going on there. So there is a mass is held. So it's the last mass that is held at a coronation.
把帽子抛向空中。把帽子抛向空中，据推测他们是为此拿了报酬的。我的意思是，所有这些事情都是这样。我的意思是，有趣的事情，把它和加冕礼进行对比，是我们对加冕礼了解不多。而且对于天主教仪式的确切地位、那里到底发生了什么，存在一些混乱。所以举行了一场弥撒。所以这是加冕礼上举行的最后一场弥撒。
It's the last one in Latin. Yeah, for a while anyway. Until George I comes. Yeah. Yeah. But Elizabeth is saying that there is a mass, but she didn't participate in it. And so there's a general sense of muddle and confusion. And so I've read several scholars who suggest that this confusion was kind of deliberate, that she hasn't yet entirely worked out how she's going to fuse
这是最后一次用拉丁语进行的弥撒。是的，至少有一段时间是这样。直到乔治一世到来。嗯。嗯。但是伊丽莎白说有一场弥撒，但她没有参与。所以有一种普遍的混乱感。因此我读了几位学者的文章，他们认为这种混乱在某种程度上是刻意造成的，她还没有完全想好她将如何融合
the various elements. Because basically, it's kind of the Church of England will end up looking Catholic, and its doctrines will be Protestant. Yes, I suppose that's... Being very, very reductive. The Elizabethan settlement is a muddle, isn't it? Yeah. And that the coronation is awkward for Elizabeth. You know, she knows that whatever she does, she'll be sending out signals. And it may be that at that point, she's not yet ready to send out signals. And so a veil is discreetly drawn over it, and people are encouraged not to write about it.
各种元素。因为基本上，英国国教会最终看起来会是天主教的，而它的教义将是新教的。是的，我想那是……这非常非常简单化。伊丽莎白的宗教妥协方案是一团混乱，不是吗？是的。加冕礼对伊丽莎白来说很尴尬。你知道，她知道无论她做什么，她都会发出信号。可能在那个时候，她还没准备好发出信号。因此，人们谨慎地掩盖了这一切，并被鼓励不要对此进行书写。
And instead, it is actually the procession that matters. That's where the messages are going out, which in turn would suggest that the key thing for Elizabeth is less what's going on in the Abbey than what's happening on the streets. Yeah. And her Englishness, I think, is the fact that the first of those pageants is about her descent from Elizabeth of York and Henry VII, Henry Tudor, the people who ended the Wars of the Roses and brought national unity and all this sort of thing.
相反，真正重要的是游行。信息就是从那里传出去的，这反过来又表明，对伊丽莎白来说，最关键的不是威斯敏斯特修道院里正在发生的事情，而是街上正在发生的事情。是的。我认为，她的英格兰本土特色体现在第一场盛装游行与她的血统有关——她源自约克郡的伊丽莎白和亨利七世、亨利·都铎，正是这些人结束了玫瑰战争并带来了国家统一以及诸如此类的事情。
And she has no Spanish blood. And that's also really important that they're sort of heavily emphasising her kind of native-born Englishness. Yeah, so in 1561, she tells the Scottish ambassador, the Mary Queen of Scots ambassador, and shows him her finger on it. It's the coronation ring that had been given to her at the ritual by the Archbishop of Canterbury.
她没有西班牙血统。这也是非常重要的，他们在大力强调她那种本土出生的英国人身份。是的，所以在1561年，她告诉苏格兰大使，即苏格兰女王玛丽的大使，并让他看她手指上的戒指。那是坎特伯雷大主教在仪式上赠予她的加冕戒指。
And she's still wearing it. And she says that I am already married to the realm of England when I was crowned with this ring, which I wear continuously in token thereof. So before we come to another Scott, James I or James VI of Scotland, obviously Shakespeare has a fair bit to say about anointing and balms and oils and all this, doesn't he? Absolutely. So we're talking about how the coronation ritual under Elizabeth is, the look of it is Catholic, the doctrine of it is becoming Protestant. What, therefore, is the role of the coronation? What is the role of the anointing? Does it make a king or a queen someone holy, or does it not? Shakespeare's history plays relentlessly explore that issue. Shakespeare writes a play about Richard II who gets deposed by Henry IV and has probably the most famous expression of this idea that an anointing transfigures the person to whom it's done. So not all the waters in the rough road sea, Richard II says, can wash the balm off an anointed king. But of course, Richard II does end up deposed. And in fact, at one point when the
她现在还戴着它。她说，当我戴着这枚我一直戴着作为信物的戒指加冕时，我已经嫁给了英格兰王国。因此，在我们谈论另一个司各特，詹姆斯一世或苏格兰的詹姆斯六世之前，显然莎士比亚对涂油礼、圣油和所有这些有很多话要说，不是吗？绝对的。所以我们正在讨论伊丽莎白统治下的加冕仪式是如何的，它的外观是天主教的，它的教义正在变成新教的。因此，加冕礼的作用是什么？涂油礼的作用是什么？它使国王或女王成为神圣的人，还是没有？莎士比亚的历史剧毫不留情地探讨了这个议题。莎士比亚写了一部关于理查二世的戏剧，他被亨利四世废黜，并且可能是对这一观点最著名的表达，即涂油礼使接受它的人发生了蜕变。因此，理查二世说，波涛汹涌的大海中的所有水，都无法洗掉受膏君王身上的圣油。但当然，理查二世最终还是被废黜了。事实上，有一次，当
Earl of Essex is staging his rebellion and he pays for Richard II to be staged, Elizabeth says, I am Richard II, no, you're not that. So she's very alert to the kind of political implications of these historical stories and the way that Shakespeare is framing it. But of course, Shakespeare is absolutely still alert to this idea that a king or queen who is anointed, thereby, in a way, his or her fate will determine the fate of the kingdom. So whether that's in Richard II, where all kinds of terrible things are reported, or Macbeth, or whatever, that idea is really fundamental. But at the same time, you're getting the idea that is actually expressed by henry the fifth in the play named
埃塞克斯伯爵正在策划他的叛乱，他出资上演理查二世，伊丽莎白说：“我就是理查二世，不，你不是那个。”所以她对这些历史故事的政治寓意以及莎士比亚建构这些故事的方式非常警觉。当然，莎士比亚仍然绝对警觉于这种观点，即一个受膏的国王或女王，因此，在某种程度上，他的或她的命运将决定王国的命运。所以无论是《理查二世》中报道了各种可怕的事情，还是《麦克白》，或者其他什么，这个想法确实是根本性的。但与此同时，你在戏剧中也得到了由亨利五世实际表达的观点
after him that you know that all the crown and the mace and the whatever the robes and the swords and the scepters and things are really nothing that what matters is the man within yeah because he calls it the farcid title running for the king so in other words this is all flummery this is all wallpaper and just spin and nonsense and And actually what matters is the character. Yeah. And so that is a division. Does an anointing make a king holy, or is it the character of a king? And is all the anointing simply the window dressing? Well, see, what's fascinating to me about this, Tom, and actually what reading about this brought home was we know that all these people, they have their reigns.
以他的名字命名的戏剧，你知道，所有的皇冠、权杖、无论是什么样的长袍、宝剑、节杖等其实都算不了什么，真正重要的是里面的人，是的，因为他称之为给国王穿的虚伪头衔。换句话说，这都是虚饰，这都是墙纸，只是公关和胡扯。实际上重要的是性格。是的。所以这是一个分歧。涂油礼使国王神圣，还是国王的性格使然？所有的涂油礼都只是门面装饰吗？嗯，看，汤姆，关于这一点，对我有吸引力的是，实际上阅读这些内容让我深切体会到的是，我们知道所有这些人，他们都有各自的统治期。
We know the story. What it really reinforces is for so much of this period, how insecure they all are. Even Elizabeth I, there's been Tudors before her, but the Tudor dynasty are not that old. And she's still, there's that insecurity, there's the anxiety, there's the need for massive security often massive spectacles you know the propaganda all that and is it doesn't that shed a kind of interesting light on the 17th century in a way that i'd never thought of before that the course the two extremes that you come to have in the 17th century are the divine right of kings that kings are absolutely appointed by god that they have a sacral status that is greater than that of
我们知道这个故事。它真正强化的是，在这一时期的很大一部分时间里，他们是多么缺乏安全感。即使是伊丽莎白一世，她之前有过都铎王朝的统治者，但都铎王朝并没有那么悠久的历史。她仍然——存在那种不安全感，存在焦虑，需要大规模的安全保障，通常需要宏大的奇观，你知道，宣传所有这些——难道这没有以一种我以前从未想过的方式为17世纪照亮了一道有趣的光芒吗？那就是你在17世纪自然会遇到的两个极端是君权神授，即国王绝对是由上帝指定的，他们具有比主教甚至还要伟大的神圣地位；或者根本不应该有国王，而应该建立一个共和国。这就是17世纪发生那么多事情所围绕的双极。当詹姆斯一世在1603年南下时，他是苏格兰的詹姆斯六世，所以他已经加冕过了，确保安全。所以我们知道他支付了500名士兵的薪水，他们每天拿八便士来防范威斯敏斯特的骚乱和混乱。因为当然，有很多焦虑。英国民众会如何忍受一个虽然是新教徒、虽然有王室血统，但却是个苏格兰国王的人呢？所以他和妻子丹麦的安妮一起南下了。从一开始，
bishops even, or that there should be no king at all and there should be a republic. And those are the twin poles around which so much happens in the 17th century. When James I comes down in 1603, James VI of Scotland, so he's been crowned already,ive security. So we know that he pays 500 soldiers, they're paid eight pence a day to guard against tumults and disorder in Westminster. Because of course, there's a lot of anxiety. How will the English crowds put up with, admittedly a Protestant, admittedly of royal blood, but a Scottish king? So he's come south with his wife, Anne of Denmark. Right from the beginning beginning there's a degree of sort of trouble and disappointment because there's an outbreak of plague in london so the
就存在一定程度的麻烦和失望，因为伦敦爆发了瘟疫，所以
procession is hugely cut down and they tell spectators do you know do social distancing which people obviously ignore because that's as people so often do they make a special new translation of the liber regardless that thing that you were talking about that the order of service episode yeah and they take out a lot of the tudor stuff and they take out anything that they think is contrary to church of england doctrine so anything that is too catholic they translate it into english although the oath he still makes the coronation oath he makes in latin and english, interestingly, this surprised me, in French, because he is still technically King of France. King of France, yeah. So he makes it in French.
游行规模大大缩减，他们告诉观众，你们知道吗，要保持社交距离，人们显然忽略了这一点，因为人们经常这样做，他们不顾一切地为《礼拜仪式书》制作了一个全新的翻译，也就是你刚才谈到的那个秩序服务的那集，是的，他们删去了很多都铎王朝的东西，删去了任何他们认为违背英国国教教义的东西，所以任何过于天主教的东西，他们都把它翻译成英文，尽管宣誓部分——他仍然进行加冕宣誓——他是用拉丁语和英语宣誓的，有趣的是，这让我感到惊讶，他是用法语宣誓的，因为在技术上他仍然是法国国王。法国国王，是的。所以他是用法语宣誓的。
Massive crowds, despite the fact it's raining. Obviously, he's reunited with the Stone of Destiny, which is a nice moment. Nice for him, yeah. Yeah, it's lovely. But there's trouble with his wife, Anne of Denmark. She's Catholic, isn't she? So she had originally been Lutheran, and then clearly exposure to the Scots drove her to the opposite extreme. Because then she seems to have secretly become a Catholic. Even the Pope himself said, it's very hard to work out what game she's playing, is she Catholic or not? But she refuses
尽管下着雨，还是有无数的群众。显然，他与命运之石团聚了，这是一个美好的时刻。对他来说很美好，是的。是的，这很可爱。但他的妻子丹麦的安妮带来了一些麻烦。她是天主教徒，不是吗？所以她最初是路德教徒，后来显然苏格兰人的影响把她推向了相反的极端。因为后来她似乎秘密皈依了天主教。连教皇本人也说，很难弄清楚她在玩什么把戏，她到底是天主教徒还是别的什么？但她拒绝
to take communion. And she's the first of three queens that do that. So Henrietta Maria, who then marries Charles I, and Catherine of Braganza, who marries Charles II, all Catholic, all refuse to have anything to do with the coronation ritual. In 1626, so when Charles I takes over, now Charles I needs less security than James I. James I, there have been plots and all sorts of gunpowder plots, but he's got away with it. He's got through and died peacefully in his bed. Charles I takes over, a general sense of sort of, you know, there's rejoicing and there's all this sort of stuff. But Henrietta Maria, who he's just married, he thinks they'll have a joint coronation as kings and queens usually do. But Henrietta Maria refuses to go. She watches because she's a strict Catholic.
领圣餐。她是连续三位拒绝领圣餐的王后中的第一位。所以亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚（后来嫁给查理一世）和凯瑟琳·布拉干萨（嫁给查理二世）都是天主教徒，都拒绝参与加冕仪式。1626年，查理一世接位，现在查理一世需要的安全保障比詹姆斯一世少。詹姆斯一世时期曾发生过阴谋和各种火药阴谋，但他都挺过来了。他熬了过去，安详地死在床上。查理一世接位时，有一种普遍的喜庆气氛，你知道，大家都在狂欢等等。但是他刚娶的亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚，他原本以为他们会像国王和王后通常那样举行联合加冕典礼。但亨丽埃塔·玛丽亚拒绝出席。她只是在一旁观看，因为她是一个虔诚的天主教徒。
She says, I'm not doing any of this Protestant nonsense. So she just watches, apparently, from a window while he is crowned. Well, she wouldn't want anything to do with heresy, would she? So we were talking about omens. They're all stories now told about Charles I's coronation. And do these date to after 1649? Of course. Yeah, I found them in a Victorian book.
她说：“我才不搞这些新教的胡闹呢。”所以当他加冕时，她显然只是从窗户里看着。嗯，她可不想和异端扯上关系，对吧？所以我们之前在谈论预兆。现在流传着很多关于查理一世加冕礼的故事。这些故事是在1649年之后才出现的吗？当然是的。我在一本维多利亚时期的书里找到了它们。
So there's some sort of golden dove that is part of the regalia. Very sinister. And a wing breaks off and falls to the floor with a clatter. The dove from above. I read you this Victorian book. It says, the Bishop of Carlisle, Richard Sennhouse, made an inexcusable blunder, Tom. Oh, no. He took as the text of his coronation sermon,
所以有一只金鸽子是王权信物的一部分。非常不祥。然后它的翅膀断了，伴随着哐当一声掉到了地上。来自上天的鸽子。我给你读了这本维多利亚时期的书。上面说，卡莱尔主教理查·森豪斯犯了一个不可原谅的错误，汤姆。哦，不。他把加冕布道的经文选为：
be thou faithful unto death and I will give thee a crown of life. See, I don't see that as an inexcusable blunder, because I don't really know what that means. But anyway. He'll be martyred. Presumably this was an anticipation of martyrdom. But also the thing, Charles was later regarded to have worn the wrong clothes. So he turned up in a suit of white satin.
“你务要至死忠心，我就赐给你那生命的冠冕。”你看，我不认为这是一个不可原谅的错误，因为我其实不知道那是什么意思。但无论如何。他会殉道的。据推测，这是对殉道的预料。但还有一件事，查理后来被认为穿错了衣服。所以他穿着一身白色缎子西装出席了。
And, of course, he wears a white shirt on the day of his execution when it is also snowing and very cold so eagle-eyed observers said could see that no good would come no good would come of this white suit now we're about to uh go on to try saying but before we do that cromwell has a kind of coronation doesn't he he does. We said in the previous episode that he becomes Lord Protector sitting on the throne, the throne of St. Edward over the Stone of Scone. So I dug this out.
而且，当然，在他被处决的那天，他也穿着一件白衬衫，当时还在下雪，天气非常冷，所以目光锐利的观察者说，可以看出这套白色西装不会有好下场，不会有好下场。现在我们准备进入审判，但在那之前，克伦威尔举办了一种加冕典礼，不是吗？是的。我们在上一集里说过，他成为护国公，坐在宝座上，那是圣爱德华的宝座，位于斯康石之上。所以我把这个挖出来了。
It's his second investiture in 1657 is the really big one. The first one is a bit of a sort of, they do it in a cupboard or something. Yeah, hugger mugger. Yeah. The second one, he's been offered the crown and he said no. Reluctantly. But they say, well, we'll have a coronation anyway. You know, who cares?
这是他在1657年的第二次授权仪式，这是真正意义上的那次盛大仪式。第一次有点像是在一个储藏室里举行的那种。是的，鬼鬼祟祟的。是的。第二次，人们把王冠献给他，而他拒绝了。很不情愿地。但他们说：“好吧，无论如何我们都要办个加冕礼。你知道的，谁在乎呢？”
So they have a big ceremony in Westminster Hall. He wears velvet robes, ermine. There's a big sword. There's a scepter. The spectator hands all this stuff over to him, the Bible, the scepter, and the robe and the sword. He swears an oath. I do in the presence and by the name of god almighty promise and swear that to the uttermost of my power i will uphold
所以他们在威斯敏斯特大厅举办了一个盛大的仪式。他穿着天鹅绒长袍，上面有貂皮。有一把大宝剑。有一把权杖。旁观者把所有这些东西都交给了他，包括《圣经》、权杖、长袍和宝剑。他宣誓。我以全能上帝的名义并在其面前庄严承诺并发誓，我将竭尽全力维护
and maintain the true reformed protestant christian religion blah blah blah blah and to my power i was chief magistrate of these three nations uphold the maintenance and preservation of the peace and safety and the rights and privileges of the people. So in other words, he's got an oath that looks very like a coronation oath. And when it's all done, there's heralds, there's trumpets, and they say, His Highness Oliver Cromwell, protector of England. And the crowds outside, again, almost certainly money has changed hands or K-bonds or whatever people are being bribed with. They shout, long live his highness,
并保持真正的改良新教基督教信仰，blablabla，并尽我作为这三个国家最高长官的权力，维护和平与安全的维持和保护，以及人民的权利和特权。换句话说，他有一份看起来非常像加冕誓言的誓言。这一切完成后，有传令官，有号角声，他们说：“护国公英格兰的奥利弗·克伦威尔殿下。”外面的群众，再次地，几乎可以肯定是金钱易手了，或者是K债券，或者人们被行贿了。他们高呼：“护国公殿下万岁，
long live his highness, huzzah, huzzah, huzzah. I would definitely say huzzah. You know my views on the Lord Protector, Tom. Yeah. And would you wear a cap and throw it at the air? Undoubtedly. And then I would go and rip off a bit of the carpet as a souvenir, I think, just to improper. And start a riot. Exactly. Start setting fire to things. Exactly. But meanwhile, of course, there is a king, a real king. So Charles II had been crowned in Scotland, hadn't he? On New Year's Day, 1651.
护国公殿下万岁，乌拉，乌拉，乌拉。”我绝对会喊乌拉。你知道我对护国公的看法，汤姆。是的。你会戴上一顶帽子把它扔向空中吗？毫无疑问。然后我会去扯下一块地毯作为纪念品，我想，只是为了不得体。然后挑起一场骚乱。没错。开始放火烧东西。没错。但与此同时，当然，有一位国王，真正的国王。所以查理二世已经在苏格兰加冕过了，不是吗？在1651年的元旦。
At Scone, a traditional place. So he's had one coronation already. He comes back in 1660, and then he's finally crowned in April 1661. Do you know what the Bishop of Winchester, how the Bishop of Winchester described Charles at his coronation? The new King John. A barrel of laughs. As a figure like Christ.
在斯康，一个传统的地方。所以他已经有过一次加冕典礼了。他在1660年回来，然后终于在1661年4月加冕。你知道温彻斯特主教是如何形容查理在他的加冕典礼上的吗？新国王约翰。真是个开心果。形容得像基督一样。
Really? Who had risen from the dead. You amaze me. But I mean, Charles II, the comparisons between him and Jesus aren't obvious. Well, Charles II's coronation, Tom, not inappropriately for the restoration, is attended by some quite bad behavior. So Samuel Pepys writes an absolutely splendid description of going to Charles II's coronation. He goes to the abbey and he says, the king in his robes, bareheaded, it was very fine. Pepys says there's all sorts of rituals and ceremonies, but in very amusing Pepys way,
真的吗？从死里复活的人。你让我大吃一惊。但我的意思是，查理二世，他和耶稣之间的比较并不那么明显。嗯，查理二世的加冕典礼，汤姆，对于复辟来说，非常应景地伴随着一些相当糟糕的行为。所以塞缪尔·皮普斯写了一篇极其精彩的描述，关于去参加查理二世的加冕典礼。他去了威斯敏斯特修道院，他说，国王穿着长袍，赤着头，非常棒。皮普斯说，有各种各样的仪式和庆典，但用皮普斯非常有趣的方式，
he says, I couldn't actually see them because the crowd was too thick and I couldn't see over all the partitions and stuff. So that's very disappointing. Peeps hears a big shout. Interestingly, a good sign of his political talents. At the coronation, Charles II has his Lord Chancellor read out a general pardon to people for their behavior in the Civil War. So he's got one eye on conciliating the disagreements. People throw medals around. Why are they doing that they're gifts you know throwing out little silver
他说：“我实际上看不到它们，因为人群太拥挤了，我无法越过所有的隔断之类的东西看到。”所以这非常令人失望。皮普斯听到了一声巨大的呐喊。有趣的是，这显示了他的政治才能。在加冕典礼上，查理二世让他的大法官向人们宣读了一份大赦令，原谅他们在内战中的行为。所以他一只眼睛盯着化解分歧。人们到处扔奖牌。他们为什么这么做？那些是礼物，你知道的，扔出一些小银
coins it was a bit dangerous peeps is disappointed because he doesn't get any himself so again he's missed out the music strikes up peeps says so great a noise that i could make but little of the music and indeed it was lost to everybody and then says, but I had so great a lust to piss that I went out a little while before the king had done all his ceremonies. So Peeves has missed almost everything. That's a tradition, isn't it? Of people who attend coronations being advised not to drink. Because if it's going to be 12 hours or even seven hours.
币，这有点危险。皮普斯很失望，因为他自己没有得到任何银币，所以他又错过了。音乐响起，皮普斯说：“噪声太大了，我几乎听不清音乐，事实上音乐对每个人来说都消失了。”然后他说：“但我尿急得厉害，所以在国王完成所有仪式之前不久，我出去了一会儿。”所以皮普斯几乎错过了所有事情。这是一个传统，不是吗？参加加冕礼的人会被建议不要喝酒。因为如果时间长达12个小时甚至7小时的话。
So then Peeves goes to the banquets. And this I had not realized until delving into this subject. They would always have the banquet at Westminster Hall hall but there would be thousands of spectators who were behind rails watching everybody have the feast so peeps is one of the spectators and he sees somebody who knows who gives him some bread and then somebody else who you know some of the bigwig gives him a bit of rabbit so he has a sort of sandwich with some friends a little snack i wouldn't watch other people have a bank i I mean, watch Prince Harry have a... Tom, you know perfectly well that it's quite hard to persuade me to leave my house to go
然后皮普斯去了宴会。这一点直到深入研究这个主题之前我才意识到。他们总是在威斯敏斯特大厅举办宴会，但会有成千上万的观众站在栏杆后面看着大家享用盛宴。所以皮普斯是其中一个观众，他看到一个认识的人给了他一些面包，然后另一个人——你知道的，某个大人物给了他一点兔子肉，所以他和几个朋友做了一个三明治，吃了一点零食。我才不会看别人吃宴会呢。我是说，看着哈里王子吃……汤姆，你非常清楚，很难说服我离开家去
for a dinner, which I'm actually going to eat, let alone one in which I'm going to watch other people eating. Yeah, I do. So then they all go, he goes off with his wife and what he describes characteristically is a pretty lady, a doctor's wife and various other people. And they go out drinking and stuff. And he says, it's strange to think that these two days have held up fair till now that all is done and the king gone out of the
吃晚饭，更不用说去那种只能看着别人吃的地方了。是的，我知道。所以他们都走了，他和他的妻子一起离开，他带有典型色彩地描述了一位漂亮的女士、一位医生的妻子以及其他各种各样的人。他们出去喝酒什么的。他说：“奇怪的是，这两天天气一直很好，直到现在一切都结束了，国王走出了
hall and then it fell a raining and thundering and lightning which people did take great notice of and they said it was god's blessing of the work of these two days and he says it's a foolery to take too much notice of these things so peep says skeptical spirit of the royal society exactly these are mugs however peeps then disgraced himself tommy hasn't finished his wife goes off to bed he goes out with some gallants and they drink the king's health so this is coronation evening and then he says um we did this and nothing else till one of the gentlemen fell down stark drunk and lay there spewing peeps goes to bed with one of these blokes. But not the one he's vomited.
大厅，然后就开始下雨打雷闪电，人们对此非常关注，他们说这是上帝对这两天工作的保佑，他说太傻了，对这些事情过于关注。”所以皮普斯展现了皇家学会的怀疑精神，没错，这些都是傻瓜。然而，皮普斯随后让自己丢脸了，汤姆，他还没说完。他的妻子上床睡觉了，他却和一些花花公子出去喝了国王的祝酒词——所以这是加冕典礼的当晚——然后他说：“嗯，我们一直在做这个，直到其中一个绅士烂醉如泥地倒下，躺在那里呕吐。”皮普斯和一个这样的人上床睡觉了。但不是那个吐了的人。
No, a different one. That'd be horrid. And then Peeps says, but then my head began to hum and I to vomit. And if ever I was foxed, it was now, because I fell asleep and slept till morning. Only when I waked, I found myself wet with my spewing. Thus did the day end with joy everywhere. It's interesting because Pepys was very sympathetic to the Commonwealth,
不，是另一个。那太可怕了。然后皮普斯说：“但后来我的头开始嗡嗡作响，我也开始呕吐。如果我曾经喝醉过，那就是现在，因为我睡着了，一直睡到早晨。直到我醒来，我发现自己身上沾满了呕吐物。”这一天就这样在各处的欢乐中结束了。这很有趣，因为皮普斯对共和联邦非常同情，
wasn't he? So he's kind of jumped ship. Pepys is a bit of a trimmer though, isn't he? I mean, that's one of the nice things about Pepys. Right. And so talking of trimming, Charles II is followed by his brother, James II, who is Catholic. Yes.
不是吗？所以他算是在某种程度上跳船了。不过皮普斯有点像个骑墙派，不是吗？我的意思是，那是皮普斯可爱的地方之一。没错。说到骑墙派，查理二世之后是他的弟弟詹姆斯二世，他是个天主教徒。是的。
He has two coronations. It's a secret coronation. A private one. Yeah. The Catholic one. And then he has the one in Westminster Abbey. Yes. And his reign goes horribly wrong
他经历了两次加冕典礼。这是一次秘密的加冕典礼。私人性质的。是的。天主教的那次。然后他在威斯敏斯特修道院又举行了一次。是的。他的统治出了大问题，
and he gets replaced by his daughter and her husband, William and Mary. That's right. I will say one thing about James II's coronation though, Tom. We have the most amazing description of it by a guy called Francis Sanford, whose book I think is in the British Library. And he has that list that's been circulating on Twitter in the last week or so with everything that people ate. So there's hundreds and hundreds of dishes, crayfish,
他被他的女儿和女婿威廉和玛丽取代了。没错。不过，关于詹姆斯二世的加冕典礼，汤姆，我要说一件事。我们有一篇由一个叫弗朗西斯·桑福德的人写的关于它的极其精彩的描述，我想他的书在英国图书馆里。他有那张在过去一周左右在推特上流传的清单，上面列出了人们吃的所有东西。所以有成百上千道菜，小龙虾，
fricassees, ragouts. Ragouts? Well, you can tell he's a rotter. Exactly. And going to end up going to France. Frenchified. Pure absolutism. Absolutely. So if you've listened to our podcast on the roast beef of old England, you will know that the Rest is History podcast is not a friend of the ragout or the fricassee.
肉末浓汤，法式炖菜。肉末浓汤？好吧，你可以看出他是个坏蛋。没错。最后还要去法国。沾染法兰西习气。纯粹的专制主义。绝对的。所以如果你听过我们关于“英格兰老烤牛肉”的播客，你就会知道“历史的其余部分”播客并不是法式炖菜或肉末浓汤的朋友。
Well, no, I am. Well, Tom is because of his Frenchified Holland house, Wiggish Ways. Yes, but you with your russet coat. Yeah, precisely. I'm very much team 1657. Team K-pop. Right. So, yeah, James is kicked out.
好吧，不，我是。好吧，汤姆是的，因为他那法兰西化的荷兰式住宅和辉格党的作风。是的，但你穿着粗呢大衣。是的，确切地说。我非常支持1657年团队。K-pop团队。好吧，所以，詹姆斯被赶走了。
And now his daughter, Mary, is going to be crowned along with William III. And so this is what you opened with. Yeah. The episode. The Broadside Ballad. The crowning of William and brave Queen Mary. This is an unusual one because they are joint monarchs, which England has never had. Right.
现在他的女儿玛丽将与威廉三世一起加冕。这就是你开篇时谈到的内容。是的。这集节目。大字单页民谣。威廉和勇敢的玛丽女王的加冕。这是一个不寻常的加冕，因为他们是联合君主，这在英格兰历史上从未有过。没错。
So that question of whether it's 40 or 38 monarchs that have been crowned in Westminster Abbey depends on whether you include Harold Godwinson. Which you'd surely do. Well, there's no hard evidence though. That's never stopped us in the past, Tom. That's not us. I'm saying the canonical list. Okay. The list to get on the ruler. And whether you just bundle William and Mary in as one or whether they're crowned separately. And I think they are crowned separately. Yeah, because they have separate crowns. There's a great discussion about whether or not she will have Mary of modernness. Because a whole new set of regalia had to be made for Charles II because it was all smashed up in the interregnum, in the Carmel years. So is Mary II going to have Charles II's wife's crown or is a consort's crown not really good enough?
所以关于威斯敏斯特大厅加冕的君主到底是40位还是38位的问题，取决于你是否把哈罗德·戈德温森算在内。你肯定会算上的吧。嗯，不过没有确凿的证据。这从未阻止过我们过去这样做，汤姆。这不是我们的风格。我说的是规范的名单。好吧。进入统治者的名单。以及你是把威廉和玛丽捆绑为一个，还是让他们分别加冕。我想他们是分别加冕的。是的，因为他们有各自的王冠。关于她是否会戴现代的玛丽王冠，有一场激烈的讨论。因为查理二世必须制作一整套新的王权信物，因为它们在空位期，即克伦威尔统治的几年里全被砸碎了。那么玛丽二世是要戴查理二世妻子的王冠，还是配偶的王冠其实不够好？
And actually, at first people say a consort's crown not really good enough and actually at first people say consort's crown is not good enough but they basically run out of time and money part because it's been the glorious revolution there's a real rush to have the coronation to establish their legitimacy so they say listen stop faffing around with the crowns just get on and crown them so she does have a basically a bit of a sort of a knock me down a bit of a pound shop crown yeah yeah it's very sad and this is the first one at which you get the coronation oath that is the glorious revolution revolutionary settlement coronation oath that basically charles iii will be inheriting this weekend that they have to defend um the protestant reformed religion
实际上，一开始人们说配偶的王冠不够好，但实际上他们基本上耗尽了时间和金钱，部分原因是经历了光荣革命，有一股真正的急迫感去举办加冕典礼以确立他们的合法性，所以他们说，听着，别再为王冠的事瞎忙活了，快去给他们加冕吧。所以她基本上戴了一个有点打折的、像两元店买来的王冠。是的，是的，这太悲哀了。这是第一次你得到了加冕誓言，也就是光荣革命结算的加冕誓言，查理三世这个周末将要继承这个誓言，他们必须捍卫……
established by law exactly so that's still part of that's still part of the deal so that broadside ballad that i read out to the beginning i mean that spirit is enshrined in law to this day kicking out yeah opry all that sort of stuff and of course when william and mary get succeeded by anne mary's sister yes and then she dies without issue because she's just been having rabbits as people remember who've seen what's that that film called? Oh, The Favourite. The Favourite. Anne, poor old Anne. I know, poor old Anne. Anne is 37 when she's crowned, 1702.
法律确立的新教改良宗教，没错。所以这仍然是……这仍然是协议的一部分。所以我刚开始读的那首大字单页民谣，我的意思是，这种精神至今仍被写入法律中，驱逐，是的，噢，所有这些东西。当然，当威廉和玛丽由玛丽的姐姐安妮继承时，是的，然后她死时没有子嗣，因为她一直在养兔子，正如看过那部电影的人所记得的那样，那部电影叫什么名字？哦，《宠儿》。《宠儿》。安妮，可怜的老安妮。我知道，可怜的老安妮。安妮在1702年加冕时37岁。
She couldn't walk there, could she? She's so large. So portly. She has to be... Carried in a litter. She has to be carried into the coronation. She's wearing a wig and false curls made by Mrs. Ducayla. We know from her account books, a petticoat that costs 30 shillings from made by mrs banks nice and everyone says she
她不能走着去，对吧？她太胖了。太丰满。她不得不……被抬在轿子里。她不得不被抬进加冕典礼。她戴着由杜凯拉夫人制作的假发和假卷发。我们从她的账簿中得知，有一条价值30先令的衬裙是由班克斯夫人制作的，很好，每个人都说她
looks splendid lots of jewels lots of gold all this sort of stuff a special crown flaming with diamonds apparently great they think about anne i mean some people like to think of anne as you know a very important political player wigs and to. I know you like Anne because of the king's evil. Yes. So that becomes a marker of the sacral status of a monarch, is that they can cure scrofula. They have supernatural powers. They touch you and then... Which is a result of being anointed. Right. So there's still, for a defender of the Protestant reform religion established by law, the idea that you get anointed and then go around curing people of scrofula doesn't entirely gel with that.
看起来光彩照人，有许多珠宝、许多黄金以及所有这些东西，一顶镶满钻石闪闪发光的特殊王冠，显然很棒。人们对安妮的看法，我的意思是，有些人喜欢把安妮视为一个非常重要的政治玩家，假发等等。我知道你喜欢安妮是因为“国王之病”。是的。所以这成了君主神圣地位的一个标志，即他们能够治愈瘰疬。他们拥有超自然的力量。他们触摸你，然后……这是受膏的结果。没错。所以对于法律确立的新教改良宗教的捍卫者来说，你接受涂油礼然后四处帮人治愈瘰疬的想法，与这种宗教并不完全契合。
And one of the people that she's meant to have cured is the young, the future Dr. Johnson. When he was two, I think. So you would be given a coin called a touch piece, a special souvenir, better than a piece of carpet. Also better than a medal. And he wore it around his neck for the rest of his life. He was a very, very devout Tory Church of England man. Exactly, he was.
据说她治愈的人之一就是年轻的、未来的约翰逊博士。我想他当时两岁。所以你会得到一枚被称为“触摸币”的硬币，一个特殊的纪念品，比一块地毯要好。也比一枚奖牌要好。他在余生中一直把它挂在脖子上。他是一个非常非常虔诚的托利党英国国教徒。没错，他是。
So because I knew you were interested in this, I thought this would never sustain an entire podcast, The King's Evil. So I'll find a fact to surprise Tom with. Okay, great. Who do you think touched more people than any other for The King's Evil? Charles II. Oh, have you been doing your own research? No, I knew that. Do you know how many people he touched for The King's Evil. Charles II. Have you been doing your own research? No, I knew that.
所以因为我知道你对这个感兴趣，我想这绝对无法支撑起一整期关于“国王之病”的播客。所以我找了一个能让汤姆感到惊讶的事实。好吧，太棒了。你认为谁为了“国王之病”触摸过比其他人更多的人？查理二世。哦，你一直在做自己的研究吗？不，我知道这个。你知道他为了“国王之病”触摸了多少人吗？查理二世。你一直在做自己的研究吗？不，我知道这个。
Do you know how many people he touched for the King's Evil? How many did he touch? 92,000. 92,000. Okay, I didn't know that. Not all at once. Wow. Were they all very pretty?
你知道他为了“国王之病”触摸了多少人吗？他触摸了多少人？92,000人。92,000人。好吧，我不知道这个。不是一次性完成的。哇。他们都很漂亮吗？
That was right. And women. Exactly. Exactly. Come here, my darling. Another 20-year-old actress with the King's Evil? Surely not. You've all got sc graph, you know.
那是对的。还有女人。没错。没错。过来，我的小宝贝。又是一个患有“国王之病”的20岁女演员？怎么会。你们都得了皮肤病，你知道的。
Yeah, no, incredible. So it had not been a thing, but the Stuarts really went all in on it because it had only actually been quite a niche activity until the Stuarts. And then Charles II, I suppose you can absolutely understand why. He's been restored.
是的，不，这太不可思议了。所以这以前并不是一回事，但斯图亚特王朝真的全力以赴地去做了，因为在斯图亚特王朝之前，这其实只是一项非常小众的活动。然后是查理二世，我想你绝对可以理解为什么。他复辟了。
He's a bit insecure. Well, it's like we've been talking throughout this episode that it's the usurpers and the people who worry that the foundations of their regime aren't secure. Exactly. Who have to go all in with the sacral stuff. Exactly. So we've come to the end of the Stuarts. Tom, of all the coronations we've done so far, which would you most have liked to have been present at?
他有点缺乏安全感。嗯，就像我们在这一整集中一直在讨论的那样，是那些篡位者和担心他们的政权基础不够牢固的人。没错。他们才不得不全力以赴地搞那些神圣的东西。没错。所以我们来到了斯图亚特王朝的尾声。汤姆，在我们迄今为止做过的所有加冕典礼中，你最想亲临现场的是哪一个？
That's a very, very good question. Apparently, Richard II was brilliant. Really? He wore slippers that supposedly had been owned by Edward the Confessor. And there was a kind of general aura of sophistication and class. Okay. So maybe that one. What about you?
这是一个非常非常好的问题。显然，理查二世的加冕典礼非常精彩。真的吗？他穿的拖鞋据说曾属于忏悔者爱德华。而且有一种高雅和阶级的总体氛围。好吧。所以也许是那一个。你呢？
I think it's hard to beat the one we started with. The Edwy. The revolting pigsty behaviour. Goes off and has a threesome. Yeah, but you wouldn't get to see the threesome. No. Well, unless you went in with St. Dunstan. I can't imagine you
我觉得很难超越我们开头提到的那个。埃德威。那令人作呕的猪圈般的行为。跑去搞3P。是的，但你又看不到3P。不。嗯，除非你和圣邓斯坦一起进去。我无法想象你
hanging out with saint dunstan i don't think he's put up with you for long really i mean no offense oh great thank you for that maybe i'll go with um i don't know i'd go in the oil of a cromwell one just so i could shout huzzah and throw my cap in the air and hurrah for the lord protector yeah wear my kind of russet coat of a of a yeoman all. Yeah. But then I'd turn my coat, obviously, in time to go drinking with heaps. Drink for King's health.
会和圣邓斯坦混在一起，我觉得他不会忍受你太久的，真的，没有冒犯的意思。哦，太棒了，谢谢你这么说。也许我会选择……我不知道，我会去克伦威尔的加冕礼上，只是为了能大喊“乌拉”，把我的帽子扔向空中，为护国公万岁欢呼，穿着我那种自耕农的粗呢大衣。是的。但随后我当然会见风使舵，及时赶去和皮普斯一起喝酒。为国王的健康干杯。
Wake up in the morning. Exactly. Right. So we will be back next time with some absolutely tremendous coronations. So the Georges, they're excellent coronations generally.
早上醒来。没错。好吧，所以我们下次会带着一些绝对震撼的加冕典礼回来。所以乔治王朝时期，他们的加冕典礼通常都很棒。
There's some very ludicrous behaviour at those. There's massive overspending. There's lots of things going wrong and things being dropped. And then we'll go right up to the coronation of our dear late queen in 1953. And we'll end with some suitable sentiments about the new Carolian age, I think. Will we, Tom? Looking forward to that?
其中有一些非常滑稽的行为。有巨大的超支。有很多事情出错，东西掉落。然后我们将一直讲到我们敬爱的前女王在1953年的加冕典礼。我想我们将以对新卡洛琳时代的适当感言来结束。我们会这样吗，汤姆？期待那一刻吗？
I think so, yes. Why not? Why not? All right. So we shall see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. looking forward to that i think so yes why not why not all right so we shall see you next time bye bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod
我想是的，是的。为什么不呢？为什么不呢？好的。所以我们下次再见。拜拜。拜拜。期待那一刻吗？我想是的，是的。为什么不呢？为什么不呢？好的。所以我们下次再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。这就是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这就是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
dot com that's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦绯闻，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告内容、独家番外节目并优先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。